the school of life has always felt very
close to the German language in general
and to Switzerland in particular that's
why we're so pleased to announce that we
are at last coming to Zurich with a big
three-day conference that we're going to
be running starting on Friday the 12th
of October 2018 taking place in Zurich
University of the Arts this is a three
day event about everything we care about
at the School of Life emotional
intelligence wisdom self understanding
love friendship and meaning the
conference will mirror what happened in
our conferences in Lisbon Portugal in
October 2017 and San Francisco USA in
March 2018 that means we'll have
lectures in the day
great meals together the best kinds of
interactions and chats about everything
that matters late into the night it'll
be a true chance to experience a
globally minded community dedicated to
learning kindness self exploration and
wisdom the conference lasts three days
and is led by our founder and creative
lead Alain de Botton and will feature
our best teachers and our very best and
most transformative ideas if you're
interested in coming to Zurich to meet
us in October please click on the link
on screen now you'll learn a lot
returned with a huge number of useful
new ideas and make friends for life we
hope to see you there